Ukraine's military says is shot down 18
missiles launched at the Capitol on
Monday night officials say the attacks
were exceptional and involved cruise and
ballistic missiles as well as drones
people have been urged to remain indoors
or in bomb shelters
we heard it all even our Windows shook
but thank God there were no missiles in
our area
no my friends my classmates and I we
heard it all they were all worried and
one of my classmates houses got hit I
think it's terrible
we're going to cross live to live
Natasha Butler is joining us from there
what more do we know about these attacks
on Kiev
they are very difficult nights for
people in Kiev as you heard there this
wave of Russian attacks drones and
missiles including we understand
Hypersonic missiles uh Ukrainian uh
defense officials say that most of these
joints and missiles were intercepted by
Ukrainian air defense systems so what we
have is a situation which we understand
that there were no casualties there were
no people injured at least not as far as
we know but there was some damage in
terms of some building particularly as
debris was falling down and that is why
people were told to continue to take a
shelter until the situation calmed down
now these attacks by Russia have
intensified since uh the beginning of
the month and they came just a few hours
after a Ukrainian President Vladimir
zelensky arrived back in Ukraine he had
spent the last few days in Europe
speaking uh to uh Western leaders there
as he aims to shore up more where
happens for Ukraine and more support
ahead of a highly anticipated uh
counter-offensive of course we don't
know when that counter offensive will
take place we don't know where it will
take place but there is no doubt the
Ukrainian forces are preparing they say
that they still need weapons and there's
a lot of pressure on Ukrainian forces
they have exceeded expectations since
this Invasion began last year of course
but the reality is that a few people
believe that this counter-offensive will
be Ukraine's loss or will in any way end
the war Natasha Butler Natasha thank you